et selon notre journaliste antoine
boitel spécialiste des questions
sécuritaires les policiers terrain sont
remontés en usage de mettre en place un
service minimum dans plusieurs
commissariats français après le meurtre
par balle d'un policier du groupe
départemental d'intervention qui étaient
venus prêter main forte à ses collègues
sur un point de trafic avignon et
fonctionnaires de terrain loin des
arcanes syndicats sont très en colère
des sources me parle même d'un contexte
de défiance dans certains commissariats
d'île de france
les grandes familles syndicales ont bien
saisi que cette colère policière n'était
jamais vraiment redescendu depuis 2016
avec viry châtillon alors ils réagissent
vite très vite
les annonces des actions dès le
lendemain de la mort du policier
de fait en croire mes sources la base
policière est déjà sur le pied de guerre
elle risque même de déborder à la fois
les syndicats et l'administration
si une réponse satisfaisante n'est pas
accordée à leur colère alors que deux
fonctionnaires ont été tués en moins de
deux semaines
aussi le témoignage très vif que j'ai
reçu de la part d'un policier anonyme
d'associations de policiers en colère
coupé unis ce matin à qui je demandais
quelle était l'ambiance aujourd'hui dans
son commissariat et quelle était la
position des policiers en colère en
dehors des syndicats
je cite si les syndicats ne font rien
s'ils ne réagissent pas et vont se faire
dépasser donc nous nous voulons qu'ils
réagissent mais sans récupération et
sans faire n'importe quoi les jeter de
menottes les rassemblement s'est terminé
les collègues n'en veulent plus car je
cite ce sont des opérations à la con
les collègues veulent une modification
des textes ils veulent une appréciation
correcte des juges
et surtout ils veulent le service
minimum tant que rien ne sera mise en
place
nous appelons donc les collègues à ne
sortir que sur mission urgente pour le
reste l'administration ira se faire voir
voilà ce que me dit ce policier et il
ajoute donc les opérations qu'ovide et
toutes les conneries comme ça c'est
terminé
mais avant de conclure nous appelons au
service minimum
nous demandons une vraie implique pénale
et nous voulons que dharmanand se bouge
surtout voudrions que dupont moretti
parts dans le nord et qui n'en
reviennent